salut à tous et je vais vous faire un
petit point avant de commencer cette
vidéo des niayes s'amuse à 1 censuré mes
vidéos à chaque fois que je mets des
images de son film j'ai décidé de ne
plus diffuser l'image de son film à la
place je vais citer paraphraser et faire
des reconstitutions pour ne pas vous
confondiez mes citations avec ce que je
pense moi même je vais divisé l'image
comme ça ici vous aurez la scène
reconstituer cité ou paraphrasant pour
respecter la paternité de l'oeuvre
je vais vous mettre ici la jaquette du
film de demian juste bar là je vais vous
mettre le time code si vous voulez
vérifier la source
vous n'aurez qu'à aller à ce timing par
là je vais mettre la vignette de la
vidéo au cas où ces images seraient
reprises hors contexte et je vais
rajouter une mention ce qui est cité
dans le film où ce qui est dit dans le
film par ici en plus de ça tous les
passages cités je vais vous mettre une
petite nocturne de beethoven en musique
de fond un petit peu voilà comme ça je
l'amenais normalement vous ne pourrez
pas croire que ce qui est dit dans ce
cadre
c'est ce que je pense vraiment où ce que
pense éventuellement d'autres personnes
qui auraient participé à cet épisode
merci beaucoup et mobile
il est le nettoyeur demi
complotistes mes amours bonjour je suis
ravi de vous retrouver pour ce nouveau
nettoyeur de mythe et aujourd'hui on va
se pencher sur l'autre terre des dieux
un film de demian sorti en 2010 est
pourquoi ce film tout simplement parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une recrudescence
des chercheurs de vérité et ce film est
le premier d'une longue liste à venir
le problème c'est que la vérité n'a pas
le même sens dans la bouche des
scientifiques et dans celle des
chercheurs de vérité alors qu'allez vous
bien dans vos sièges allumez vos
cerveaux et c'est parti pour les
nettoyages
le film qui va suivre traite de sujets
très controversée en roumanie
il expose certaines découvertes et
théorie qui ne peuvent être prouvées à
ce jour mais qui lève le voile sur des
cultures méconnus et négligés
oui mais non une théorie c'est prouver
là déjà ça part mal
son objectif n'est ni d'affirmer ni de
convaincre mais de suggérer et proposer
d'autres réponses que les théories
enseigner et c'est là où ce film est
vraiment révolutionnaire
aucun chercheur ne s'amuse à suggérer ou
proposer des choses sans être affirmatif
ou convaincant je pense qu'on va
assister à une première le genre de film
qui dira ah ouais je dis que c'est ça
mais j'y crois pas trop en même temps je
aucune preuve mais j'ai pas besoin
d'avoir de preuves pour vous dire que
c'est ça puisque de toute façon je ne
cherche pas à vous convaincre
et puis même sans chercher à vous
convaincre le but final du film c'est
que vous sachiez quand même que les
gouvernements et les archéologues vous
cache la vérité la roumanie que savons
nous de ce pays en réalité bien peu de
choses
c'est quand même triste pour un film qui
va parler d'un sujet de nous avouer dès
le début qu'il y connaît rien moi quand
je connais rien je me renseigne
là par exemple j'ai tapé d'as sur percer
alors percer c'est juste une base de
données qui regroupe article compte
rendu et communication scientifique à
l'échelle mondiale j'ai donc tapé d'as
et je suis tombé à l'heure où le script
a été écrit sur pas moins de 4000 sans
référence donc petite note pour les
chercheurs de vérité
arrêtez de confondre l'ignorance
scientifique avec votre flemme à taper
des mots clés dans des bases de données
internationales
merci nombreuses sont les découvertes
archéologiques qu'on tente de dissimuler
sa fait 2 minutes que le film a commencé
et on est déjà dans le complot il ya une
chose qui veut dissimuler des preuves
archéologiques
le problème c'est qu'il ne doit pas être
très doué parce que le bas on en parle
actuellement mais bon passons et voyons
ce que les gouvernements ont essayé de
cacher mais comme ils sont trop stupides
pour les laisser caché correctement
ça a fuité et voilà nous vous
dévoilerons d'anciens sanctuaire des
trésors mystérieux des objets
archéologiques hors du commun qui
pourrait remettre en question toute
notre histoire qui pourrait remettre en
doute toute notre histoire vous avouer
que celle là je sais pas si je leur ai
tenté
bah ouais il ya moins de trois minutes
vous nous avez dit son but n'est ni
d'affirmer ni de convaincre du coup je
me demande quelle partie de cette intro
et mensongères ouais parce que rien
affirmer et ne convaincra personne tout
en remettant en doute tout autre
histoire
ce concert sacrément ambitieux comme
plan et là on voit un joli citadelle das
reconstitué dans une 3d du plus bel
effet et on nous dit qu'elle a plein de
trucs super des habitations des étables
et des systèmes complexes d'adduction
d'eau je vous présente hasard mises et
gains tout ça une citadelle das oui mais
qui n'est pas plus impressionnante que
des constructions grecque ou romaine
si on prend par comparaison l'aqueduc de
l'agneau vétus deux cents ans plus vieux
que cette citadelle où le tunnel de palm
eos en grèce qui est six ans en plus
anciens et pour info le tunnel d'opaline
hausse c'est un aqueduc souterrain qui a
traversé une montagne de part en part
pour se retrouver au milieu avant le
juge et la complexité d'une construction
il faut regarder ce qui se fait un peu
au tour toutes ces constructions
on nous dit qu'elles ont des
installations modernes et ce avant que
les romains interfère avec la culture
d'as des constructions modernes ça veut
dire des constructions à partir de 1492
les choses modernes en gros c'est la
renaissance
si les daces avait eu là pour il se
serait pas fait botter le cul par rome
et pas de contact avec rome
il ya pas mal d'historiens et
d'archéologues qui sont pas d'accord
avec ça en fait tous il ya des échanges
commerciaux entre l'italie du nord et la
dacie depuis le premier millénaire avant
notre ère et l' influence de la culture
villano viennent elle est présente
partout en roumanie
donc si la culture s'y trouvent déjà
trois quatre siècles avant la fondation
officielle de rome
c'est qu'il ya une influence des peuples
du nord de l'italie sur la dacie au
vième siècle avant notre ère les
échanges avec la grèce sont courants et
on retrouve beaucoup de céramique et
d'objets en bronze grecque
honda si on peut noter aussi que les
celtes ont beaucoup influencé les daces
ne serait ce que sur le culte mort on
retrouve des tombes avec des chars comme
on peut en trouver sur le bord du rhin
ou dans la marne il faut savoir aussi
que le commerce est très prospère
puisqu'on retrouve en roumanie des
monnaies grec du ivème siècle avant
jésus-christ et des monnaies romaines du
3e siècle avant jésus-christ c'est à ce
moment là qu'on nous montre une statue
d'un type barbu qui s'appelait décennies
un prêtre influents qui nous dit-on
aurait été initié en egypte au même
titre que thales pythagore et platon
donc le type s'est pas franchement
n'importe qui essaient de 8 dans les
daces aurait tiré leur savoir et même
que certains disent que c'est lui qui
aurait fait construire la cité
on touche un sacré problème avec
décennie où ce prêtre qui a transmis
tout un tas de savoir audace déjà les
sources décennie où il nous est connue
grâce à jordan est un auteur go nevers
480 et il a écrit vers 550 donc ce qui c
par décennie ou de jordan s c'est ce qui
me séparent mois de edouard cisse roi
d'angleterre et d'irlande
il n'est pas historien et il mélange
tout un tas de trucs fantastiques avec
ses récits on sait pas trop ce qui est
vrai ou pas bon maintenant les lieux on
nous dit au même titre que thales
pythagore et platon en egypte bon déjà
on a absolument aucun texte qui nous
dicte décennie où est allée en egypte
est le seul qui parle d'un d'as en
egypte ça fait référence à zale beauxis
et on va en parler plus tard ce temple
astronomique aurait servi de calendrier
est pas un calendrier tout pourri
puisqu'on nous dit qu'il était le plus
précis de l'antiquité car à côté il y à
une dalle dans des hits un cadran
solaire cadran qui servait audace à
prédire les équinoxes et les solstices
réputé pour être le plus précis de toute
l'antiquité
alors là ça me pose plusieurs problèmes
soit c'est le calendrier le plus précis
du monde antique actuellement mais dans
ce cas là il faudrait tracer une liste
de tous les calendriers antique connu et
si vous avez des bons plans
je suis preneur à noter aussi que a
remisé gay tout ça a été détruite
pendant la conquête puis reconstruite
après le passage de l'armée romaine ou
alors on accepte que les daces ait eu
des liens avec les autres civilisations
antiques et la balle problème c'est que
les auteurs le calendrier il en parle
pas du tout même diodore de sicile qui
est contemporain de la construction de
la citadelle
il parle de stonehenge mais il parle pas
du tout du calendrier donc niveau
réputation antique on peut émettre des
doutes quand même à part ça et pour
revenir sur le côté précisions par
rapport au soleil
je vous rappelle qu observer les astres
c'est autant un loisir que religieux
que culturel qui a pas de comics il ya
pas de bouquins n'y a pas de signer ils
ont même réussi à esquiver cyril hanouna
quand on voit qu'aujourd'hui on est
encore capable d'observer la récurrence
et la fréquence dans le mouvement des
astres faut arrêter de voir nos ancêtres
comme des bourrins de télé réalité bon
alors là la voix off de la dame nous dit
que les historiens savent très peu sur
les d'ascq il leur attribue un niveau de
connaissance limitée et bien que
beaucoup affirmant qu'il ne connaissait
pas l'écriture
les historiens en savent très peu sur
les nas non si on regarde les quelques
4000 publications scientifiques
historiens et archéologues n'en savent
pas très peu sur les daces contrairement
visiblement à l'équipe de réalisation de
ce film
quant aux connaissances très limitées
j'attire votre attention sur le lien
subtil qui est fait entre écriture et
intelligence je vous invite à admirer
les pierres dressées les dolmens ou
l'artisanat celte par exemple les
civilisations mégalithique et les celtes
n'écrivait pas ou très peu pour les
celtes aucun chercheur ne fera jamais de
lien entre pas d'écriture civilisation
stupide je vous laisse méditer là dessus
claudio sic les tablettes de sinaia
montre qu'il possédait bien l'écriture
500 tablettes ont été trouvés 19e siècle
pendant la construction du château de
pech 1
concernant les tablettes de sinaia il ya
deux problèmes qui se posent
le premier c'est qu'aucune source
concernant la construction du château
n'évoque cette découverte d'or et la
seconde c'est que je n'ai pas trouvé de
sources concernant les tablettes qui
date d'avant les années 90 donc on a du
mal à les croire authentique une voix
off nous dit que pour récupérer lors de
ces plaques le roi carol premier aurait
fait des copies en plomb
puis il a fait fondre les copies en or 1
pour récupérer le flouze et la mr2
arrive et nous dit qu'il ya une forme de
grec ancien qui nous a permis de
traduire quelques mots sur certaines
tablettes que ça évoquerait les
chroniques de décès balle qui est un roi
das certains signes ne sembleraient
avoir des similarités avec les signes
arabique et pourront encore en plus des
historiens et les archéologues évoque
des personnages au style perse ou
arméniens j'ai laissé cet extrait parce
que demian va réagir et analyser le
passage par la suite
donc nous avons supposément des
tablettes en or avec trois langues dont
une d'un style arabique la langue arabe
remonte au deuxième siècle de notre ère
le roi des c bâle a vécu à la fin du
premier siècle
donc on a en gros entre 50 et 100 ans
d'écart entre des régions qui n'ont pas
vraiment communiqué sauf si encore une
fois on dit que les das ont tous apporté
à tout le monde en mode nationaliste et
bien entendu je ne sais pas de quel
historien et archéologue on parle ici
puisque personne n'est cité elles ne
sont pas les seuls à mettre ensemble
trois types d'écriture différentes comme
la pierre de rosette des chercheurs
pensent que si elle avait était
authentique
elle n'aurait pas été fondue le roy
carroll était déjà très riche il
n'aurait pas eu besoin de l'or des
tablettes
il faut quand même le reconnaître ne
retrouver nulle part ailleurs la même
écriture
ces suspects et même si ce lieu avait
été un genre de bibliothèques das
regroupant toutes les langues du monde
on devrait retrouver des traces
archéologiques d'occupation d'as ce
n'est pas le cas
et contrairement à ce que dit demian
c'est pas du tout le fait qu'ils aient
trois écritures différentes sur les
tablettes qui empêche les archéologues
et les historiens de dire que ces
tablettes sont authentiques un petit
point sur la pierre de rosette
les trois écritures différentes sont sur
la même pierre c'est un petit peu ça son
intérêt d'ailleurs là ça serait un peu
comme de prendre un texte français un
texte anglais et un texte japonais même
si les textes sont différents mais ça on
peut pas le savoir sur maîtrise pas les
langues et d'un coup magie magie on va
les mettre côte à côte et se dire allez
si ça se trouve va réussir à traduire un
truc si les textes ne sont pas liées
physiquement c'est totalement hasardeux
de tenter des traductions au pif
on parle de carole premier un gars qui a
refusé les premiers plans de ces
architectes parce que ça sonnait trop
châteaux de la loire et il pouvait pas
se le permettre financièrement et second
point en plein milieu de la construction
de ce château entre mille
177 et 1878 on a ce qu'on appelle la
guerre d'indépendance de la roumanie est
une guerre ça coûte de l'argent
donc oui le roy carroll était peut-être
très riche mais dans tous les cas ils
avaient besoin de l'or pour faire la
guerre donc soit les plaques sont
fausses
soit carole premier a eu toutes les
raisons de les fondre pour récupérer de
l'or on a le premier intervenant daniel
roque saint qui nous parle de syndrome à
l'eau un archéologue célèbres qui ont
réussi à prendre en photo 200 tablette à
l'institut archéologique de bucarest
mais quand daniel roque saint seiya
vendus il n'en a trouvé que 34 et il
affirme donc que certaines tablettes ont
disparu sans laisser de traces
et c'est le retour de notre grand jeu
qui est le spécialiste daniel roques
sain et bien c'est un nationaliste pur
et dur clamant à qui veut l'entendre que
les das ont conquis roms et non pas
l'inversé
comme tous les nationalistes il croit
que son peuple descend d'un peuple das
plus ancien que les autres et que tous
on s'appuyait sur aucune source sérieuse
il a le mérite d'être honnête et ne
revendiquent absolument aucun diplôme en
histoire archéologie ou linguistiques et
se présente comme auteur mais il se
permet de raconter un peu tout et
n'importe quoi et produit de nombreuses
vidéos de pseudo archéologie avec des
thèmes comme l'histoire cachée des das
ou autres calendriers mystique 2 à
remiser gay tout ça et puisque dan
romalo a pris les photos où sont ces
photos vous me direz ça permettra aux
gens de continuer à faire des recherches
en marge et de rêver un petit peu c'est
curieux ce léger fumée de complot en
mode
le gouvernement nous cache quelque chose
et ça entre totalement en contradiction
avec le fait que l'on sache qui a pris
les photos de quoi sont faites des
photos et combien il y en avait ou alors
parce qu'elle annoncerait que les daces
n'était pas si primitif
ouais donc l'état aurait détruit des
tablettes pour empêcher qui que ce soit
d'affirmer que les daces n'était pas si
primitif non mais sérieusement si un
pays veut fédérer sa population tout en
glorifiant son passé il aurait aucune
raison pas le faire mais bref
maintenant que le décor est posé voyons
qu'ils sont et das le peuple das fait
beaucoup parler de lui en roumanie
d'après les historiens c'est comme si ce
peuple était sorti de nulle part
sorti de nulle part mais n'importe quoi
et la marmotte et le chocolat c'est
pareil aussi non si vous en doutez
encore je vous renvoie aux 4000
références scientifiques sur les das
je vous mets le lien dans la description
les textes de philosophes comme hérodote
où platon
tarissent pas d'éloges à leur égard
alors qu'on soit clair cinq minutes
hérodote c'est un historien c'est même
presque le premier historien reconnu au
monde c'est pas un philosophe et platon
est née quand hérodote est mort donc il
se peut très bien que la mention desalle
beauxis chez platon soit totalement
pomper de chez hérodote
quant aux loges et bah je sais pas où
vous les avez trouvés parce que moi je
les ai cherchés et à part à dire ils
connaissent des charmes magique pour
soigner et ben y'a pas grand chose à
l'écran un monsieur mais explique que
les d'asson dieu pour été présenté comme
un peuple barbare et primitif
alors qu'en réalité je le cite nous
découvrons une culture exceptionnelle
qui a considérablement influencé la
culture grecque
bah ouais on parle de barbares primitif
tout simplement parce que c'est des
auteurs grecs qui vont en parler et donc
tout ce qui parle pas grecs ou romains
pour les périodes suivantes
ça sera considérée comme barbare et puis
tant qu'on est sur une influence si en
dha si on retrouve des céramiques
grecque mais pas l' inverse
c'est peut-être parce que la grèce a
influencé la dacie et pas l'inversé
justement le même personnage poursuit en
réalité quand nous parlons d'orphée
dionysos apollon artemis et d'autres
divinités et tradition grecque
il faut savoir que j'ai des crises et
j'ai pris des notes
il faut savoir qu'elles ont été
empruntés par les grecs aux traces ça le
prix de voleurs de grecs 1 c'est
incroyable ah le bon gros discours
nationaliste c'est nous qu'on a la plus
grosse la plus puissante la plus longue
et puis on a essaimé partout toutes les
civilisations nous doivent le respect
sauf qu'en fait non toutes les
civilisations qu'elle soit celte daste
grecque elles viennent des indo
européens essaient indo européens ont un
socle commun de croyance un panthéon qui
se ressemble à peu près avec les mêmes
traits les mêmes attributs pour les
dieux les mêmes fonctions tout ça se
ressemble beaucoup parce que tout est
parti d'une souche commune qu'on appelle
les indo européen du point de vue de la
culture matérielle pour savoir qui
influencent et qui entre diverses
civilisations
il suffit de voir où est ce qu'on
retrouve tel ou tel céramique si on
retrouve beaucoup plus de céramique
grecque en d'aci que de céramique d'as
en grèce c'est sûrement parce que la
civilisation grecque était beaucoup plus
enrichissantes que la civilisation das
d'autant que ni vos influences
das letras ont grandement été influencée
par les
le maire dit ceci à propos des gets un
peuple traces voyages et les jette non
pas pour leur donner des leçons mais
pour en apprendre non aux mères ne parle
pas des das il parle des traces et
plutôt ceux qui sont du côté du pont
tocsin donc au nord-est de la
méditerranée c'est là où les grecs
importer leur blé pour se nourrir donc
on est un petit peu loin de la dacie des
origines tout ça tout ça
la citation vous aurez beau fouiller
tourner et retourner au maire dans tous
les sens vous ne pourrez pas la trouver
puisqu'elle est issue des voyages de
pythagore écrit en 1798 par sylvain
maréchal
cocorico et ce récit est totalement
fantasmée et n'a absolument aucune
prétention historique
autant vous le dire tout de suite
sylvain maréchal à part ça on ne sait
absolument rien nuit alors déjà dans les
cité antique grecque on a du mal à
savoir si un texte est attribué à homère
ou non donc là un mec qui est née genre
2200 de 1300 ans après les faits ça
commence à devenir compliqué donc cette
citation non je suis désolé mais elle
vaut absolument rien le symbole du
peuple d'assez le loup symbole de
liberté d'intelligence et d'insoumission
alors le symbole da ce n'est pas né de
lui même on peut retracer son parcours
depuis la mésopotamie ensuite chez les
irano cimmérien puis finalement chez les
jette
on sait pas trop pourquoi le loup ce
serait un symbole d'insoumission est la
première vraie référence à cette
attitude date limite de la fable le loup
et le chien mais rien ne rattache le
loup à l'insoumission
à part un roman contemporain de
littérature érotique
ceci dit jouer sur les symboles c'est
aussi jouer sur le terrain des
nationalistes et peut-être tout
simplement que demian s'est fait prendre
dans un jeu bien sale dont à ce moment
là des miennes qui nous dit que le
peuple das a perdu face à rome vick
mais il dit aussi que parmi tous les
peuples européens
le peuple d'as et je n'ai pas à avoir
autant la liste et y avoir hésité aussi
férocement face à l'envahisseur un des
rares peuples avoir résisté aussi
férocement à l'envahisseur on va faire
un petit point rapide sur les conquêtes
de rome la conquête de la dda 6 et 2,88
à 106 donc ça prend 16 ans la conquête
de la gaule c'est de -58 à -51 50 donc
on va dire sept ans la conquête
d'espagne c'est de moins de 118 à -19
donc 200 ans la conquête de la germanie
ça n'a jamais été conquis totalement et
la conquête de la grande bretagne
ça a jamais été conquis totalement
niveau défense féroce
on est quand même sur le 2ème peuple à
se faire botter le cul plus rapidement
en europe antique
je pense qu'il ya pas trop de raisons de
s'en vanter et puis concernant la
victoire de trajan leroy d'as à l'époque
s'est suicidé face à trajan ou alors ces
aristocrates qui l'ont poussé au suicide
en tout cas on reste sur du bon mensonge
nationaliste et c'est dommage alors là
c'est la séquence où on voit des tas de
statues érigées par trajan sur un arc de
triomphe où on dit qu'elles ont été
érigés pour faire honneur audace et que
c'est bien surprenant du coup qu'est ce
que c'est un arc de triomphe un arc de
triomphe à rome s'est construit après
une victoire militaire avant de pouvoir
revenir à la vie civile
c'est sensé commémorer les grandes
batailles les grandes victoires
l'arc de triomphe qui est ici présenté
c'est l'arc de constantin pas celui de
trajan il a été construit entre 312 et
315 alors que trajan et empereur de 53 à
sinon les statuts ce sont des
prisonniers de guerre sans arme ni
armure et en fait c'est plutôt
l'humilité qui représentait n'oublions
pas que le peuple vaincu fait maintenant
partie de l' empire
ça serait dommage de les rabaisser et de
créer des révoltes
si on va plus loin il faut se poser la
question du symbole le plus
représentatif
la louve qui allaitent romulus et rémus
il faut se poser la question de ce qui
est le plus logique et rationnel un loup
qui nourrit élèves deux enfants ou bien
la culture d'as qui nourrit m
sous-entendu influence l' empire romain
alors si je résume
rome a pris comme symbole la louve pour
reconnaître une subordination à la dacie
sa patrie mère il faut arrêter de dire
de la merde je suis désolé demian mais
quand comme toi on n'a aucune
connaissance du symbolisme politique
anti qu il vaut mieux la fermer plutôt
que sortir des hypothèses miteuse comme
celle rome elle est habitée depuis le
xème siècle
sa fondation a été décidé arbitrairement
en 753 avant jésus-christ par tite-live
qui se basait lui-même sur des textes du
2e siècle avant jésus-christ la louve
c'est un animal qui est consacré à mars
et mars c'est le protecteur de rome ne
faut pas s'étonner que rome choisissent
comme symbole un animal qui représente
son dieu tutélaire et pour les petits
malins qui voudraient jouer sur les mots
non rome n'a pas commencé à vénérer mars
après avoir découvert la dacie merci les
guerres de dacie se passe entre 80 206
après jésus-christ donc de deux choses
l'une soit comme le dit le film leda se
sont construit tout seul sans aucun
rapport avec les autres civilisations
jusqu'à 82 et dans ce cas là le loup
symbole de rome ne doit pas apparaître
avant 81 2 donc mars ne doit pas
apparaître avant 81 2 donc là le film en
soit le film nous ment sur les relations
entre la dacie et le reste du monde
nous le savons via les vestiges
archéologiques la dacie et le nord de
l'italie sont reliés économiquement
depuis premier millénaire avant notre
ère il faudrait donc prouvé que les
daces posséder un dieu mars dont le
symbole était la louve et que la dacie
et influencer roms et non pas l'inversé
dans ces deux cas l'autre terre des
dieux au moment où se trompe soit par
manque visible de recherche soit parfois
partisane envers les pseudos chercheurs
nationaliste roumains les dimensions
exceptionnelles des statuts attire notre
attention bien plus grande que celle
érigée en mémoire des soldats romains
elles atteignent 3 mètres de hauteur il
se pourrait que l'on porte rageant est
admiré la bravoure de cette nation mais
une autre théorie nous questionnent
serait-il probable que les statuts soit
sculpté à l'échelle de leurs modèles
concernant la taille exceptionnelle de
ses statuts il faut savoir qu elles sont
tirées de l'arc de triomphe de trajan
qui a été démontée pour être installé
sur l'arc de triomphe de constantin afin
de symboliser la pérennité du régime
politique
romain l'arc de triomphe de constantin
mélanger des éléments de l'arc de
triomphe de marc aurèle d'adrien et
d'autres agents de fait dire que ces
statues sont exceptionnellement grande
étant donné qu'on ne connaît pas la
taille des autres éléments de l'arc de
triomphe originel disparu c'est un
argument fallacieux et puis tout le
monde représente l'ennemi vaincu de
façon grande et magistral personne ne se
vantent à dire j'ai vaincu un peuple
dessous maire de c'était trop facile
non personne ne dit ça et non non non ce
n'est pas une théorie c'est une
hypothèse hasardeuse mais c'est une
hypothèse
préparez-vous cela dit on pas rentrer il
chez les gens là on est dans un musée et
on nous présente différents objets et ça
commence par d'étonnants bracelet vous
savez ce sont des bracelets de bras
alors cela ils font entre 9 et 13 cm de
diamètre entre 700 g et 1 kg ils sont
faits en or et ils sont ornés de têtes
de serpent
ils ont plutôt joli alors apparemment ça
des nôtres et d'une technicité complexe
et très élaborés et l'archéologie
roumaine pense que il était destiné à
des rituels ou à une certaine élite das
concernant ces bracelets il est
important de noter trois choses
premièrement la région dans laquelle ils
ont été trouvés connaît ce type de
brasser depuis plus de trois siècles
deuxièmement le contexte de découverte
ils ont été trouvés enterrés soit comme
étant un dépôt votifs des bien enterrée
pour des dieux soit nous aurions à faire
un dépôt de sauvegarde
on enterre des biens précieux pour que
l'ennemi ne les trouve pas lorsqu'il
raid ou conquiert la région enfin
n'oublions pas que army guézet tout ça
est une capitale religieuse et il se
pourrait que ces bracelets soient
destinés à des leaders religieux puisque
nous avons retrouvé beaucoup de ces
bracelets en argent dans des tombes
d'aristocrates mais absolument aucun en
bronze dents du bas peuple
au vu des tombes fouillé par les
archéologues il semble logique que
l'argent soit réservé aux aristocrates
et lors réservée aux dieux puisqu'on ne
trouve pas ce genre de bracelets en or
dans les tombes
vraiment ils sont interpellés par la
taille des bracelets si on part du
principe que ce sont des bracelets de
poignet et non de bras ils sont
anormalement grands et même pour des
bracelets de bras ils sont trop longs
donc ceux qui les portaient deux étaient
très grand de naître ou plus partir du
principe que ce sont des bracelets de
poignet et non pas de bras c'est
totalement illogique puisque on connaît
le contexte culturel et l'air culturelle
dans laquelle s'inscrivent les
découvertes de ces bracelets en plus on
essaie de créer une théorie à partir
d'un bracelet qui serait trop grand du
point de vue du réalisateur s'est
totalement addictif
cissé inductif est illogique c'est
stupide
après on ne présente un casque
partiellement détruit avec un diamètre
avoisinant les 30 cm ce qui serait deux
fois le diamètre d'une tête normal les
spécialistes en archéologie prétendent
qu'ils seraient portés au dessus
d'autres casques prenons le cas
maintenant des casques anormalement gros
30 cm de diamètre c'est à peu près le
diamètre d'un casque de chevalier
médiéval et ça m'étonnerait que nos
chevaliers et étaient des géants de plus
nous voyons à l'intérieur de ces casques
le revers des motifs qui les parcours
nous avons donc peu de raisons de douter
des spécialistes qui nous disent que ces
casques été porté par dessus d'autres
casques ou des coiffes de rembourrage
ensuite il nous présente un plastron
dont ils savent pas trop quoi penser
il s'agirait d'un placement cérémoniel
mais qu'aucune épaule ne pourrait porter
puisqu'il a une largeur de 80 cm et
concernant ce plastron vous n'avez rien
noté vous dans les musées les armures
vous exposez à l'endroit ou à l'envers
non parce que le plastron il est bien
censé protéger le buste en s'attachant
sur les épaules non eh bien on a là le
plus beau mensonge de ces vingt
premières minutes
en réalité ce plastron ce n'est pas du
tout un plastron
cette photo a été prise le 19 avril 2014
et vous pouvez le constater dans la
vitrine on voit le cartel ce petit
panneau explicatif sur lequel tout est
noté
et si vous regardez dans l'autre terre
des dieux demian il est en face du
cartel on nous parle depuis le début du
film de das vivent en pleine antiquités
et bien cette vitrine date d'une église
du xviiie siècle
bravo belle enfumage se placeront est en
réalité la dengue ou le halo d'une
vierge à l'enfant
la couronne est porté par l'enfant et la
bague va à la main de la vierge
cette représentation est très normalisée
et si vous
p vierge à l'enfant sur google ça vous
donnera un truc du genre nous avons donc
ici en flagrant délit de mensonge et de
manipulation clairement assumé puisque
la notice de cette vitrine est écrite en
anglais en français et en roumain dans
le film nous voyons demian et son
cadreur ils sont devant ils ont
forcément lu la notice de la vitrine
ce n'est pas normal si vous avez payé
pour ce film vous pouvez bien sûr
demander des comptes à demian concernant
ce mensonge
j'ai essayé de le faire à part
reconnaître que le plastron n'était pas
anti qu il a refusé de me donner
quelques informations à ce sujet ne
pensant probablement pas que j'avais
trouvé moi même ce que c'était il
paraîtrait aussi que son équipe de
tournage est tombé pile le jour où dans
cette vitrine
il n'y avait plus de cartons explicatifs
cela semble étrange puisque la photo de
la vitrine date du 19 avril 2014 le film
a été tourné après est la vitrine est
toujours la même
pourquoi enlever un cartel alors que la
vitrine ne change pas c'est totalement
illogique
il en va de même avec cette couronne en
or au diamètre très grand elle avait
appartenu au roi ce test 3 dont le
tombeau a été découvert en bulgarie son
corps n'a jamais été retrouvé
attention avec cette couronne d'or elle
a appartenu à ce test 3 qui dirigeait le
royaume des ordres is au beau milieu de
la bulgarie actuelle c'est pas pour rien
qu'on a retrouvé son tombeau à sofia
maintenant le lien entre ce test 3 et
les das il est très lointain et vous
avez un très bel exemple d'arguments
fallacieux qu'on appelle le millefeuille
argumentatif au passage on se plaint
qu'on ne retrouve pas son corps mais on
pratique massivement l'inhumation par
incinération tout le monde assis à part
les sites qu'ils s'y mettent dans le
courant du vème siècle va pratiquer ce
type d'inhumation on brûle le corps on
ramasse toutes les cendres on met ça
dans une urne et ensuite on enterre
l'urne et même sous l'empiré romain on
va continuer à pratiquer ce type
d'animation donc on retrouve pas le
corps c'est tout à fait normal en 190
les sabbats romain tombe sur un berger
immense qui va rejoindre l'armée et qui
va devenir empereur en 235 de notre ère
maximin le thrace sereine héberger toute
l'histoire sur sa taille et sa
découverte c'est une belle légende
mais ce que le film oublie de nous dire
c'est qu'il est devenu empereur sur un
coup de bol
à cause d'une crise politique et d'un
putsch militaire il n'a pas été reconnu
pour ses qualités politiques
c'était un guerrier brutale pas très
futés bon quand il ya empereur on est
dans une période de crise politique et
son règne dure trois ans ses premières
mesures ont été faire la guerre
notamment contre les das et augmenter
les impôts
on a deux sources principales concernant
maximum de traces et revient raconte
l'accession de maximin au pouvoir il
était chef instructeur pour les
nouvelles recrues
et ce sont ces recrues qui sont venus le
voir pour le forcer à devenir empereur
on a donc un géant imbattable au combat
qui n'osent pas dire non à des nouveaux
conscrits parce qu'ils ont des armes
c'est moche absolument personne ne nous
dit que maxime à mesure plus de 2 mètres
à part dans l'histoire auguste ou
maximin le tracé dépeint comme un géant
inépuisable le problème de cette oeuvre
c'est qu'elle a écrite cent soixante dix
ans après les faits et que l'auteur mans
allègrement dans cet ouvrage
citant des sources qui n'existent pas
anti datant ses oeuvres et tous les
historiens s'accordent à dire que cet
auteur n'est absolument pas fiable
concernant cette biographie lots c'est à
ce moment là que la voix off nous dit
tranquille que les tablettes de sinaia
pour prouver l'existence des gérants
sans dec de tout ça juste parce que mes
trains d'évidence une scène murs et des
hommes qui seraient face à des géants
attendez on utilise des tablettes à
l'authenticité douteuse pour nous parler
de géant à travers une perspective aussi
désastreuse qu'en egypte antique ou au
moyen-âge mais pourtant à l'époque
médiévale ou en egypte on n'a jamais
fantasmé sur des géants on va essayer
d'amener un petit peu d'archéologie à
tout ça on a fouillé quelques habitat
das daté de 450 à 25 avant jésus-christ
en moyenne ces habitats mesure et 4
mètres sur 2 on imagine assez mal des
géants habités dans ces habitations
de plus on a retrouvé pas mal de tombes
à incinération sous les maisons ont
brûlé le corps on ramasse la cendre on
la met dans une urne
si on brûle quelqu'un qui fait un mètre
80 ou quelqu'un qui fait 4 mètres
on va pas avoir la même taille d'urnes
parce qu'on va pas avoir la même masse
et le même volume de cendres à faire
rentrer dans cette tombe à ce moment là
le fils
nous dit que sur leur bouclier un
symbole indique qu'il serait originaire
de l'hyper bord et avant que celle ci ne
seront couvertes par les glaces l'hyper
bord est historiquement c'est un mythe
une terre inconnue au nord bien plus
loin que les terres que sont censés
parcourir les grecs car oui ce sont les
grecs qui en ont parlé les premiers on
peut voir plusieurs interprétations
quant à ce symbole sur les boucliers
ça peut être une mise en relief du
hand-ball la pièce de métal au centre du
bouclier mais le dessin peut aussi être
totalement décoratifs et permettre de
reconnaître une armée par rapport à une
autre
ce qui porte ce symbole d'ailleurs ne
sont pas plus grands que l'armée qu'ils
en fassent sur d'autres tablettes et on
en revient à la notion de taille des
personnages en fonction de leur
importance comme en égypte antique où à
l'époque médiévale le fait que les
terres ne soit pas recouverte de glace
c'est une supposition tout simplement
parce qu'on dit que les cultures il
pousse correctement c'est une
thermitique on peut croire ce qu'on veut
mais à partir du moment où le mythe se
heurte à des preuves archéologiques
ça devient compliqué ce peuple
hyperboréens serait descendu vers le sud
nous voilà pour le retour du grand jeu
qui est le spécialiste
ce professeur d'histoire à la retraite
n'a jamais fait de publications
scientifiques mais se permet de donner
des conférences sur des sujets aussi
vastes que l'histoire secrète des états
unis la magie noire en passant par les
cathares et le tout sans citer aucune
source
vous le savez comme moi un chercheur qui
ne cite aucune source
c'est pas vraiment la joie de la méthode
scientifique il évoque des branches
hyper boraine sans aucun fondement et
bon courage pour chercher le rationnel
dans ses dires au maire nous dit que la
nouvelle bord et était situé entre acy
la narratrice nous dit que au maire
parle de l'hyper bord et sauf que
hérodote met en garde ceux qui
penseraient que le poème proviendrait
bière d'homère et honnêtement si
l'historien le plus proche de l'auteur a
des doutes
on aurait tort de pas douter nous mêmes
et que l'hyper bord et était au nord de
la croatie
là où vivait ddas alors que depuis le
début on nous dit que lada si elle est
en plein milieu du territoire traces et
on nous l'a montré dans le film il n'est
pas impossible que des découvertes
archéologiques était est volontairement
passé sous silence
et voilà le film nous parle de
découvertes archéologiques
volontairement passé sous silence
ben oui entre deux chansons les fausses
vérités à propos d'un peuple
il est toujours
de montrer que ce sont les archéologues
et les historiens les méchants de la
faire contrôler par un gouvernement à la
solde du fpi pour nous cacher la vérité
bon je vous rappelle quand même que le
film nous a dit qu'il ne chercherait pas
à nous convaincre
on est mal barré c'est au sud ouest de
bucarest qu'une découverte va ébranler
une conviction et notre compréhension de
l'histoire
donc on ne cherche toujours pas à
convaincre mais on va tout de même
ébranlé nos convictions et notre
compréhension de l'histoire est
maintenant un petit peu d'attention on
va se retrouver avec le plus beau
témoignage de la saison en 1926 des
archéologues persuadé d'avoir découvert
le lieu où s'était uni des tribus traces
vont faire une découverte inattendue et
on nous présente un vieil homme qui dit
avoir participé aux fouilles entre 1946
et 1954 avoir déterré près de 80
squelettes dont au moins un giro je sais
ce passage était assez long mais il
fallait que je vous le met sinon tout le
reste allait devenir très très
hermétique notez au passage qu'on
commence à fouiller en 1926 mais en
réalité les fouilles se passe entre 46
et 54
il dit qu'il a travaillé sur le chantier
jusqu'en 1951 jusqu'à ce qu'il parte à
l'armée il nous dit aussi que les têtes
de ces squelettes n'était pas comme les
nôtres ils étaient bien plus grande et
il sait de quoi il parle puisqu'il a
travaillé dans un cimetière il a exhumé
des squelettes l'homme ici interviewés
étaient ouvriers sur les chantiers de
fouilles entre 1946 et 1951
du coup nouveau changement de date on
perd trois ans on fouille maintenant
entre 1946 et 1951 le vieil homme cite
un ingénieur qui est venu de la capitale
pour faire les fouilles archéologiques
l'ingénieur leur a dit vous n'avez plus
à creuser ici ce soir
puis ils ont dressé un abri de 2 m les
archéologues venez creuser la nuit
et un homme est venu pour chercher les
squelettes de géant en voiture ils ont
emmené les squelettes de géant en camion
un carpaccio ils ont aussi trouvé du blé
dans des groupes
ça ressemblait à du blé mais c'était
noir tellement d'incohérences dans son
témoignage
l'ingénieur leur dit vous n'avez plus à
travailler mais le mec va quand même
continuer à travailler jusqu'à ce qu'il
parte à l'armée ensuite il creuse de
nuit parce que ça doit être un peu plus
mystérieux et puis ils emmènent des
squelettes de géant dans des voitures
puis en fait non dans des camions des
carpates y est ils ont aussi trouvé du
blé noir étrange dans une amphore donc
en résumé le mec s'est fait virer par le
gouvernement mais il sait absolument
tout ce qui s'est passé sur le chantier
il avait les squelettes il a ouvert les
portes pour voir ce qu'il y avait à
l'intérieur c'est un génie ce mec c'est
le n'importe quoi du témoignage des
niayes nous explique que leurs droits
étaient particulièrement boudé par
l'archéologie et pourtant c'est là que
se trouvait la plus importante citadelle
d'as il n'y a que des tranchées à la
manière de sépulture et elles sont
rebouchés
comme si on avait essayé de dissimuler
des fouilles il ya également des
arbustes épineux pour empêcher quiconque
de descendre être creusée argué d'havas
serait-elle la plus importante cité ddas
et bien contrairement à ce que dit
demian l'archéologie n'a pas du tout
bout d'aile site puisque des fouilles
ont été conduites pendant plusieurs
années les rapports de fouilles montrent
beaucoup de bâtiments en bois m'est
absolument aucune structure en pierre
c'est curieux pour une citadelle n'ont
trouvé étrange que les fouilles a été
rebouché c'est vraiment méconnaître le
contexte archéologique des années 50 on
ouvre on prend tout ce qui peut être mis
dans un musée on étudie vite fait ce
qu'on a trouvé et en bouche tout c'est
aussi simple que ça et là je vous
présente le prochain best seller de
demian le complot pour les nuls
comment protéger un site et faire que
les gens ne viennent pas fouiner en
découvrant que le gouvernement cache des
squelettes de géant mettez des arbres
qui pique
je suis dégouté je suis sûr que si on
avait mis des ronces et des aubépines à
la frontière avec la belgique en 39 la
france aurait pas été envahis pour
revenir sur quelque chose d'un peu plus
scientifique
les historiens et archéologues roumains
notamment radio voulpaix estime que
argué d'havas et a remisé gay tout ça
sont une seule et même citadelle les
sources tendent à le prouver puisque la
situation de argué d'havas par rapport
au danube correspondrait à celle de
azhar miguez est tout sauf certain
endroit témoigne de la hague
fierté des excavations là je vous avoue
ce passage me pose de gros problèmes
demian arrive il prend des céramiques
qui les embarquent sans rien demander à
personne c'est du pillage archéologiques
et je préfère prévenir les archéologues
et les défenseurs du patrimoine les
images qui vont suivre peuvent heurter
la sensibilité des personnes méthodique
et respectueux des miens dans la nature
seule avec la végétation
la voix off midi c'est en cherchant des
morceaux de ses céramiques que nous
faisons une macabre découverte et à
l'écran deignan a croupi avec un morceau
de tessons de céramique ou de poterie
creusent la terre une terre très meuble
d'ailleurs et il dégage un os deux au
wild et au chili les prend et avec ses
gros doigts comme ça et en fait c'est
une mandibule et le maxillaire
et c'est un crâne humain il faut qu'ils
les assemble il a regardé il a
évidemment eu s'arrête et il conte et le
contacter les autorités
ah ah non pardon attendant il continue à
creuser on peut constater du total
irrespect pour le squelette qu'il vient
de sortir et de son manque calamiteux de
méthodes archéologiques je vous ai dit
que c'était du pillage parce que dans
les faits c'est ce qui est montré
mais car oui il ya toujours un mais j'ai
voulu en savoir plus j'ai donc contacté
l'ambassade de roumanie le pays ayant
les mêmes loi sur l'archéologie que la
france je savais où je mettais les pieds
on m'a répondu que les autorités
roumaines estimé qu'il n'y avait pas de
pillages archéologiques donc de deux
choses l'une soit demian s'est acoquiné
avec des bons patriotes nationalistes et
sa propagande sert les intérêts du
gouvernement
ça sera curieux vu la couche de complot
que lui-même glisse dans le film même si
entre nous l'ambassade m'a confirmé que
demian avait travaillé main dans la main
avec eux ou alors tout ceci n'est qu'une
mise en scène ce qui explique pourquoi
les autorités archéologiques s'en
tamponne est donc encore une fois il se
moque de la vérité et se moque de ses
spectateurs et ses financeurs
les images donnent l'impression que la
terre est fraîchement retournée et ça ne
serait pas le premier mensonge du film
après tout nous avons ici un journaliste
qui ne brille que nicolas et passe coup
goya a eu le prix
il est né en 1967 où 69 d'accompagner un
archéologue de prestige roumain dans une
cité souterraine sous les annuler et
nicolas est parce qu goya n'a pas
seulement découvert la cité creusé sous
la roche mais aussi les êtres qui la
peuplaient et c'est reparti
qui est le spécialiste youri rédacteur
en chef d'un magazine traitant
d'ufologie il est actuellement
vice-président d'une association mêlant
nationalisme folklore et complotisme il
apparaît sur des télé poubelle pour
participer à des émissions sur des bases
souterraines extraterrestres ou encore
sur le fameux complot du cern pour
détraquer le climat puis on nous parle
d'un groupe accompagné d'un archéologue
de prestige mais dont on va taire le nom
ben oui il faudrait pas pouvoir remonter
la trace de l'expert ça serait ballot et
on arrive sur une ville géante creusé
sous la roche
mais si c'était vrai bon sens la
roumanie ça deviendrait une [ __ ] de
destinations touristiques ont freiné
parc d'attractions et ça serait super
riches
mais bon je vais vous laisser avec le
témoignage du sculpteur nicolas et passe
coup goya affirme là bas il y avait des
logements creusé dans la roche et dans
certains j'ai pu trouver des ce culte à
ce moment là le journaliste reprend en
disant que le plus spectaculaire c'était
la taille gigantesque des squelettes
nous nous retrouvons donc avec nicolas
et passe coup goya qui nous dit que du
genou au talon
il y avait bien un mètre de hauteur et
donc que ces squelettes devait faire
facilement 3 ou 4 mètres de haut ici on
a un témoignage un petit peu what the
funk
on a des archéologues et des douaniers
qui passe dans un tunnel sous le danube
et personne n'est au courant sauf une
association roumaine de culture
alternative
le problème c'est que personne ne peut
authentifier ce témoignage
on n'a aucun nom de cité ni un douanier
ni un archéologue et bah c'est le
problème du témoignage
on ne peut pas être sûr que ce qui est
dit est vrai à la suite de ça je vous
conseille de voir le film on a une jolie
légende avec des géants et une pyramide
fait en nombre c'est vraiment chouette
mais le but scientifique là dedans
m'intéresse peu donc j'ai zappé elle a
ensuite mis 6 you qui nous raconte avoir
suivi un moine dans l'arrière cour de
son abbaye où il ya une falaise
sédimentaires et sur cette falaise
sédimentaires on peut voir le corps
parfaitement momifié d'une personne a
vraiment très grande
ou alors là on prend même plus de
pincettes on attaque directement avec
les restes d'un géants pétrifiés
mais bon qui est le spécialiste andré
ayew n'est ce clou une experte en
marketing chroniqueuse dans une revue sa
chronique parle d'astrologie et de
développement personnel
elle peut aussi vous organiser une
session de renaissance personnel qui
vous coûtera la modique somme de 450
euros elle est couchée face vers le bas
comme si elle était tombée
la légende raconte que c'est un géant
qui est tombée pendant le déluge
et c'est à ce moment là où j'ai envie de
me dire mais dis-moi jamie comment ça
fonctionne la sédimentation et skg ans à
peu se pétrifier comme ça on tombant
durant le déluge
mais bon soyons fous je vais utiliser
mon joker piège à chouette on va appeler
valentine de science de comptoir parce
qu'elle est juste beaucoup plus qu'avec
moi en géosciences et tout ce qui est
sûr de la vie ni sciences de la terre
tout ça est dix mois martin comment ça
marche la sédimentation mais est ce que
un géant ça peut se pétrifier en tombant
comme ça durant le déluge
salut alors d'après la littérature
scientifique la formation géologique que
vous avez vu c'est du grès le grès basse
et du sable transformé en ruche
imaginez vous au sud des carpates les
jumelles orientale des alpes on est il
ya 23 à 30 millions d'années pendants
l'oligocène les rivières creuse le
paysage et ce faisant elle emporte avec
elle un souvenir des petits cailloux
qu'elle arrache au substrat ce sable
elles vont le charrier jusqu à leur
embouchure qui est située dans l'apparat
téthys l'a pas ratée tisser une enseigne
ans maire qui a aujourd'hui disparu mais
dont il nous reste trois reliques la mer
noire la mer caspienne et la mer d'aral
mais revenons en aux cailloux notre
sable précipite au fond des océans et ce
faisant il se faire couvrir par divers
débris d'autres couches de sable donc il
va être enterré sous toutes ses couches
la pression va augmenter et il va être
compact et donc il y aura moins d'eau
entre les différents grains mais dans
les interstices qui reste il ya quand
même de l'eau et cette eau de mer elle
est chargée en ion ces ions vous finir
par précipiter et former des minéraux
comme du quartz qui vont au final
cimenté tous les grains de sable les uns
aux autres et ça va faire du grès
comment les géologues ont réussi à
retracer cette histoire est bien tout
simplement en s'intéressant au grain de
sable qui était contenu dans le grès ils
ont regardé leur composition pour savoir
par où la rivière était passé et d'où
elle venait
leur forme parce que plus un grain et
émoussés plus il vient de loin et leur
taille cela renseigne sur le débit du
cours d'eau plus une rivière est balèze
plus elle peut transporter des gros
machin est maintenant passons aux choses
sérieuses tout d'abord j'ai regardé dans
les archives scientifique pour voir s'il
y avait trace de fossiles dans cette
couche géologique et la réponse est non
mais est ce que pour autant il pourrait
y en avoir
et ben oui et non oui parce que le graet
une roche sédimentaire et que c'est là
dedans qu'on trouve les fossiles mais le
grès et le type de roche parmi lesquels
on en trouve le moins donc déjà on part
pas très bien admettons cependant qu'un
géant soit tombé dans l'eau et que il
est fini au fond de l'océan
est ce qu'il aurait pu fossilisé bon il
faut savoir que c'est très difficile de
conserver un fossile
la plupart du temps il ya que son
squelette qui traverse les âges est
encore dans de très rares cas on
conserve aussi la matière organique ce
qu'on appelle les parties molles mais il
faut vraiment un environnement très
particulier je crois que le mieux c'est
un lac avec de l'argile au fond comme ça
on peut juste se poser se décomposer
tranquille à l'abri de l'oxygène et
voilà l'important c'est vraiment le
calme or là on est dans un delta c'est
un environnement turbulent
donc à mon avis la dépouille du géant
serait vite d articuler sans parler de
toutes les bestioles et les microbes
divers de l'époque qui aurait pu
décomposer le cadavre dans tous les cas
au mieux on retrouverait peut-être des
eaux par ci par là dans la couche mais
pas une jambe au galbe si parfait
qu'elle pourrait faire une pub pour des
collants bon alors si c'est pas un
fossile qu'est ce que c'est eh ben j'ai
cherché et j'ai fini par trouver
plusieurs publications scientifiques
dont une de 2005 qui mentionne une
structure sédimentaires particulière
qu'on appelle déry peuple classe tu en
gros c'est des morceaux de sable en
train de se sédimenter qui sont
remobilisés par le courant ça arrive
assez souvent et ça donne des structures
qui sont relativement comparable à ce
qu'on voit dans l'extrait d'ailleurs si
vous regardez bien on en voit d'autres
dans le film hamon
c'est l'explication la plus
parcimonieuse elle demande le moins
d'hypothèses il n'y a pas besoin de
supposer l'existence de géant ni
d'extraterrestres ni même d'un déluge
non c'est juste le cours d'eau de
l'époque et la maire de l'époque qui
aurait pu aboutir à ce genre de
structure dans leur fonctionnement
naturel
merci beaucoup valentine et je vous
invite à aller voir chances de comptoir
parce que c'est vraiment une bonne
chaîne mais maintenant qu'on a des
réponses un petit peu plus plausible on
va pouvoir aller voir ce qui s'est
détaché de ce géants pétrifiés à nos
pieds
des pierres ont des formes évocatrices
et ce crâne de forme humaine avec des
yeux qui ressemble à ceux d'un
extraterrestre ou alors ça c'est un
crâne de géant avec des yeux allongée
franchement je sais pas donc on
s'embarque on navigue entre des aliens
et des géants et je vous avouerai que
j'ai un petit peu peur qu'un service
gouvernemental puissant un discret mais
compétent ne vienne m'enlever plus
sérieusement on va éviter l'overdose
je vais arrêter là cette première partie
j'espère que vous avez passé un agréable
moment d'esprit critique et on se
retrouve très vite pour un prochain
nettoyage
je vais profiter de ce générique de fin
pour remercier toutes les personnes qui
m'ont aidé à préparer cet épisode pas
autant d'apparitions hygiène mentale
elle est saine un mondrian bolchévique
mad men tech pline le jeune à serment
dax s'il vendait thaumatrope jdd
specchio ce françois de primum no serré
et hugo deux confessions dit stop
bien sûr je balance leurs chaînes en
description de cette vidéo et allez-y
sans modération c'est garanti sans glee
faisait des arbres le but on voit
d'ailleurs sur mes parents ils avaient
déduit tendre omar haj la plus drôle
remarque anthony bien sûr merci à vous
tous qui partageait le travail qui
veulent garder mon travail qui
commentait pour que je m'améliore sans
cesse un énorme merci au type heures
sans qui je pourrai pas investir dans du
matos qui ne tombe pas en ruine et ça me
permet notamment de sortir cette vidéo
ah ah non pardon entendu continue à
creuser toujours eu en fait dit dans les
trous qui creuse dont des restes
excusez-moi j'ai ouï oui ah ah ah c'est
le respect qui voudraient été démis en
leurs contacts figure d'un oui la cdg 30
min
je suis comme toi ans on doit bientôt 18
ans le respect je vous souhaite plein de
bonnes choses pour 2018 et j'espère
qu'on va se retrouver très vite en live
ou ailleurs ciao
dans un monde où la science évolue
toujours plus vite
l'homme ne sait plus comment rêver aidé
par la facilité de communication sur les
réseaux le mâle temps ne se jouait de la
crédulité des masses en vendant à tour
de bras des fantasmes et des hypothèses
venus d'ailleurs face à ce crime contre
la communauté scientifique
il existe un homme un homme doué de
capacités exceptionnelles un homme qui
allie intelligence doigté le sex-appeal
d'un dieu de l'olympe et je dis pas ça
uniquement pour pêcher au bébé sa
mission réduire à néant les complots et
les mythes il est le nettoyeur de mythe
[Musique]
il faut que je te dise quelque chose
je crois que
je suis amoureuse de patrice pouillard
[Musique]
il faut arrêter de dire